لدار الازياء الفاغره الفاخره تاريخ في
اثاره الجدد فمثلا في عام 2022 احدثت
مجموعتها من الاحذيه الرياضيه غير المالفه
ردود فعلا متناقضه على مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي وذلك لحالتها السيئه وسعرها
الباهض للغايه فقد وصلت بعضها الى 1850
دولار رغم انها تبدو باليه للغايه ومتسخه
[موسيقى]
واذا نظرنا الى الوراء في وقت اطلاق
مجموعه فالنسياغاز
بشكل موحد في دروع عاكسه عاليه التقنيه
للبشر وبداء الامر وكانه غزو من قبل
لسلاله الشريره جاهزه للسيطره على الارض
وكانت علامه الازياء الشهيره والمثيره
للجدل بازيائها الغريبه اطلقت تنوره تبدو
كانها مصنوعه من سياره
سجاد السيارات المطاطي وعلى الرغم من
غرابه هذه التنوره لان الاغرب هو سعرها
فهي تاتي بسعر اكثر من 2000 دولار امريكي
يذكر انها ليست المره الاولى التي تفاجئ
العلامه التجاريه بمنتج غريب وبسعر مرتفع
اذا كانت قد كشفت عنه حقيبه تبدو تماما
مثل الاكياس اكياس زرقاء يبلغ ثمنها اكثر
من 2000 دولار في حين يبلغ ثمن كيس ايكيا
حوالي 99 سنه فقط لا تعثر على اي اختلاف
بين خلال المنتجين